I was thinking that too easy examples
okay one of which you can pretty much
just quote for me and the other one of
which I won't write us yet it'll be a
little more chicken okay I'd like us to
expand this I've deliberately not put
any funky numbers on the a and the B so
it's going to be easy if I'm on the
including zero zero one two three fourth
row of Pascal's triangle what
coefficients am I going to get out of
this thing yeah 146 41 ok so I'm going
to go a to the four there's my one then
for lots of the next one plus six lots
of whoops the next one that 24 and then
I finish again on one as I always do ok
so that's easy enough now when you look
at something like this the question of
greatest coefficient is kind of like not
even a question it's always going to be
the middle one right because that's the
way Pascoe's trade wars trachsel's
triangle works always the term in the
middle ok come in but he comes my second
example it is not always so obvious so
if I didn't say okay what about this guy
just pause remove before you start to
evaluate this ok why is this different
why is it that it's not guaranteed and
could be but why is it no longer
guaranteed that the new term will be the
biggest one or so on a mr. Destry ok
because of three but so what like why
should that make such a difference
between could be square you ok good so
the reason why it's correct the three is
the problem this 3 is going to factor in
here and here and here and here right so
he is going to be an extra 3 x therefore
he is going to be extra die and extra 27
and extra 81 ok so if i go ahead and
evaluate these let's just go with those
number that just said right this is
still gonna be able before but the next
one your for c1 will give you the fall
but then instead of writing be honest
right 3b right so this is going to end
up
being 12 a huge be there's a 3 here
there's going to be an extra nine that
comes along for the ride in here so it's
not only going to be six it's going to
be six by nine inches 50-54 right we led
up to this point there's a 27 that comes
along for the ride okay 100 hundred
eight yeah 508 cubed and then lastly
there's that three also gets raised to
the power or so that's why I go okay so
what you'll notice what you're observing
is if I've got nothing you know unusual
going on then it's going to be the
middle one or if I have an odd power up
here I won't just have one greatest
coefficient I'm going to have to why is
that yeah that's right so on the next
row packs was trying but I'm going to
get 15 10 and 10 they're both go to be
the greatest provision and then back to
find that one but here on an example
like this and basically depending on
what these numbers are depending on what
these numbers are right what you find is
that the greatest coefficient will lean
off to one side okay you can see this
one is leaning off to the right because
this term which is the one on the right
which gets bigger as I go through it's
going to get larger and larger and
larger until it overcomes what the other
coefficients are so how do I then make
this sort of more efficient because I
don't really want to always have to
write out my entire expansion to find
what the greatest coefficient is the
same for a moment you've done questions
like this right like say yesterday I
asked you to find are in such and such
an expansion tell me what the constant
term is butternut independent of X right
so obviously one way is just to write
out all the terms but that was really
inefficient so what did you do instead
what you doing there yeah you went to
the general trip okay so what I'm going
to do is let some think about this here
all i do is think about the general term
here and which one of these is going to
be the most useful to me now I actually
I don't really care about the whole term
because I'm still these a's and b's they
don't matter to me i did a variable part
what I'm really interested in is
number at the front ok so I'm going to
designate that this number I'm going to
designated a rather than T of k which is
like the whole term tecate i'm going to
call it c FK just to stand for the
competition okay to drive the table for
me to tell don't look like this
right now what I'm looking at here is
each of the terms and don't forget aight
i started terms here and what the
corresponding just the coefficient what
that corresponding coefficient is so i
just got these I've already written them
down from the previous line so I had the
numbers ok no can you see I can read
them all that and then I know okay at
some point it gets it starts to get
smaller so I don't want that anymore I
want to ban any terms after that I know
it was somewhere in the middle but I
don't know where okay the quickest way
to take advantage of the general term is
to say if i compare one term to the next
right so if you can pass successive
terms you want the ratio successor toast
to be a particular kind of number right
so for example from here to here right
if i compare c0 with c1 the ratio from
here to here is 12 right and then the
ratio from c1 to c2 is going to be 3 and
no for four and a half there's one half
okay and then from here here it's going
to be two and then from here to here
it's gonna be aa now what happens it
gets smaller right so when I compare
this ratio from one coefficient to the
next one okay what do we say these
numbers were so this one is going to be
c2 over c1 which is 12 ok so I've gotten
12 times bigger to get to the next one
from here too sorry from here to here
you're going to get four and a half
because that's what 50 for 112 years for
here to here to get to the next on I
have to double and then from here
they're here hmm i bet this is by nine
right
what's it going to be it's three three
quarters yeah 84 sorry 81 on 108 and
then the reason one who could is no next
term okay so you can see what I want is
for most of these terms it's telling me
your coefficients keep getting bigger 12
times bigger before and a half a bigger
two times me I know it's slowing down
but doesn't matter to me as long as it's
getting bigger and then the certain
point unlike no no no I don't want that
okay that's not what I'm interested in
so if i can get this point where does it
stop where does it stop that next turn
that's going to be the greatest one okay
so here's another way to say it um you
know how what we're looking for is for
this to be bigger than one you see once
it's less than one it's like a GP and
the terms of getting progressively
smaller okay what I really want is this
I want it to be greater than 1 which of
course is just another way of saying if
I assume that the constant is um so I'd
the coefficient is positive we'll talk
about negative ones later on you can see
I can just multiply through by C okay
and this is saying look I want the next
coefficient to be bigger than your
current one okay I want that to be the
condition as long as you find where that
ends that next one will be the last one
for which it keeps on getting bigger
after that you're not interested okay so
therefore put a big box around this time
this guy
if you can satisfy this inequality you
can satisfy this inequality then for
some particular value of K in our case
it was taken to okay if you can find
what value of K the biggest one that
satisfies that then the next one up you
can see it right this k plus one the
next one up will be your greatest
coefficient ok so this inequality with
this ratio in here this is where we're
going to do our lines share of work so
now rather than on this which has no
actual values of this let me give you a
proper example